would you rather your boyfriend be a  comic book nerd or an absolute Sports  fanatic comic book nerd that's hard  because when I because like with the  sports it's like they would be doing  that all the time you would never see  them yeah I don't know I love you comic  book nerds but I think I want to carry  on the convo with the absolute Sports  fanatic  so yeah we're the house divided we're  weekends would be taken over by Sports  you never be able to go anywhere because  they'd be like I have to go to this game  oh and then by the way there's a game on  Thursday through Sunday and Monday now  and then Wednesday I'd be into that  though like I'd be like you know what I  mean like what if you were not in sports  like I would like them what if they  never wanted to watch a basketball game  and it was another sport that was just  hockey oh no I'd be bored I'd be bored  but the the general that's a good  counter but the general  Sports World I would pick that because  baseball I'd be